hi Jen it's our big day I've got all the
camping gear prepared it's what we've
been waiting for you know it's been two
years since we slept outside the Apple
Store for the iPhone 6 and we thought
you know what since the pre-orders
didn't work and by the time I got my
shipping dated wooden ship until October
and then once I got that shipping date I
went back to try to get another phone
and it was still October so I said you
know what Jen let's go campout I'm ready
but we have a child this time when we
took the kid well we can just swap out
and come back and just take care of the
baby bring him in the line every little
be so excited to see him because he's
he's a cute dog all right Jen let's go
can't wait we can just come back to get
all the camping supplies later because
you know we're just gonna we've got so
many hours before the actual launch
happen I wouldn't want to have to just
carry all of our thing you know it was
crazy last time we're parked you for so
long and then when I went to pull the
car out and leave the machine was broken
and we got free parking for two and a
half days
it's a lot hotter two years ago
here's how many people are waiting now
not very many
and here to the Apple store the
unfortunate reality is we're not
actually camping out this time and let
me tell you why we're not because well
not only did I pre-order not work and
then by the time I actually managed to
try to get a phone it wasn't until
October Apple just came out and told
everyone that oh we're sorry we don't
have any plus phones for anybody who
waits in line none there's none there
are no local 7 plus phones at all not
even a Jeff black nothing nothing
available so anyone camping out
there's nothing if you don't have a
pre-order or something you're not
getting a plus it's actually very very
disappointing this is probably the most
excited that I have been in an Apple
watch in a really really long time you
want to go get t-shirts and cotton on
yeah I guess so but what I really want
to do is go get some lego minifigures so
let's go do that ok we can do that I've
got my fingers ready and ready to feel
you better hurry up because I'm gonna
get off mini futures no look the rehear
all right let's let's do some minifigure
hunting
you think like who's gonna buy some
first yeah this feels like I've had well
yes see the ones that I really want I
want the baby I want the dog with the
banana and I once these penguin oh my
godness oh boy this is a great day
hi my day was just ruined by Apple
because what they do they said that the
they have no iPhone 7 plus --is so
everybody that was enlarged oh yeah
those are they're out everything's in
here yes so we just need to be very
strategic the box we've got our first
purchase so I'm gonna buy these ones and
see what we've got give me a feel but I
don't know what to this feels like a
shield on someone's mask somebody of a
mask see if you can feel a sword goodbye
I'm lucky lads here's our first one
oh it's the the chubby guy okay I got
that one
I wanted this because it looks like
Maddie no it doesn't we can change it to
make it look like Maddie I can bTW his
eyes up a little what if he wins like a
dog show first prize for spongebob oh
yeah it's the prize dog show I with the
boxer I would not have guessed that one
let's get real in there
ha good seeing a double okay let me mark
off and then we can continue again
we think we might have found them all
this is going to be the best Lego built
ever here's the last couple the time is
now and we've got all of the many years
we were set I got a few duplicates but I
got a couple for EDD as well oh where is
down far that way oh good no he's again
what'd you get would you get less in the
bag hey please love me please yeah
anything's in there good oh well I guess
I'll go find Legos together oh my gosh I
had this thought in my mind that I was
gonna go over here and build my Legos on
the table I got rid of it I actually
thought the Aza Columbia was on a puzzle
table and then it was there that's fine
oh yeah I haven't got a replacement yet
the other one was falling apart so I got
rid of it no he's got stink soon huh I
only guess I'll put together with lego
minifigures how about that
what are you thinking
you bought a hundred feet away without
him breathing
[Music]
put all the minifigures together they
look so cute I love them so much this
mini for your baby is just the most
incredible thing I've ever seen this
little you they won on escape pinky the
spooky tales this is great this little
book opens linked to penguins and one
sets hello this is incredible ice cream
sauce is super cool
cyborg the man the baby winner the
banana is okay it looks a little cheesy
to me it's not a huge fan the boxer girl
she also has a set of hair trip the
treating devil super cute real into that
one and this is a baby Maddy I'm gonna
try to make this look more like manatee
I cancel thanks for watching let me know
if you guys end up with an iPhone do a
pre-orders you guys have trouble just
like I did makes me very sad either way
I'm gonna go out of this video and I'll
see you guys tomorrow bye maybe I'll
have an iPhone tomorrow who knows to
transfer photos for my Canon YouTube
YouTube studio Netflix upload snap and
fit cam which is a kind of a cool little
app so there's my mouse it really is
this ever in my shopping folder I've got
post mates Prime now Amazon American Air
equinox which is a gym fly Delta
OpenTable